outgoing CEO Susan bujickski last year
was talking on all the this very Topic
in Davos at the world economic Forum uh
in 2022 I want to play a clip from that
just to get a so everyone can get a
sense of how YouTube is thinking about
this you know from the top uh and then
get your reaction to the proposals that
are being laid out there
investing a huge amount to make sure
that we're fighting misinformation and
there are a number of different ways
that we look up at this so the first
would be from a policy standpoint we
would look at content that we would
think about in terms of being violative
of our policies so if you look at covid
for example we came up with 10 different
policies that we said would be violative
like an example of that would be saying
that covid came from something other
than a virus and we did see people
attacking 5G equipment for example
because they thought that it was causing
covid and the second one would be really
raising up authoritative information so
if you are dealing with a sensitive
subject like news
Health Science we are going to make sure
that what we're recommending is coming
from a trusted well-known publisher that
can be reliable if there's content
that's borderline
content that technically meets our
policy but is lower quality that's
content that we basically will not
recommend to our users our users could
still access it and then lastly we're
just really careful about what we
monetize so we always want to make sure
that there's no incentive so for example
with regard to climate change we don't
monetize any kind of climate change
material so there's no incentive for you
to keep publishing that material that is
propagating something that is generally
understood as
not accurate information
so taking down really blatant
disinformation like that 5G towers are
called are causing uh covid-19 uh you
know de-ranking certain sources up
ranking authoritative sources and then
demonetizing controversial debates that
she believes are spreading
misinformation is that an agenda that
you think is a positive one for YouTube
to be pursuing
I think it would be great to see them do
that
so they're not they're not doing it no
okay no they're not doing that hit like
but here here's my reaction to to that
because I I do think it's totally
understandable and appropriate for a
company like YouTube to not want videos
about 5G conspiracies running rampant on
a platform I I don't agree with that
though that's not true they're actually
incentivized to have a lot of material
like that in fact Google came under Fire
over the last few weeks in terms of how
it's it's spending their ad dollars and
not spending them in areas that they
told their advertisers they were
spending them
um so no I would actually argue that
they that while philosophically they may
not like the idea that they're
monetizing this type of content they are
absolutely monetizing this type of
content but they they have taken those
those that sort of stuff some of them
you can find all that stuff it's all
that stuff is there on YouTube all of it
is there right the flip side to all this
is that I've seen what happens when you
know misinformation has become somewhat
of a buzzword and I I've seen what
happens when the net uh is cast too wide
I mean even reason TV we got a strike uh
for this is a video I produced it was
about these biohackers attempting to
kind of create a knockoff uh covered
vaccine and was called medical
misinformation I mean I just happen to
know the fact that this was not MediCal
misinformation it was me reporting on
something somebody was trying to do but
it got caught and it was like
six seven months after it went up that
it got caught in this drag net yeah and
so that is the that's the kind of
impossible thing about regulating
misinformation at scale you know whether
you're a government or private company
how do you call I don't think that's
true though I don't think impossible is
the right word I think that it's early
days and oftentimes because these
companies aren't incentivized to police
themselves they do it very badly and
they do it with a with a blunt Hammer as
opposed to a scalpel and it is early
like because for sure Zach there are
people who create music on on YouTube
who get their own content flag like
really even beyond the example you just
gave like yeah really we we are
constantly being accused of infringing
or on copyright exactly and that happens
all the time now I will this we would
need five hours for this conversation I
will tell you and you know how I feel
about this stuff I made the Napster
movie yeah I will tell you that that
using copyright nip law in this area to
try to rectify this stuff is generally
disastrous right and I will and so I'm
not like some big you know let's just
come down on everyone with with harsher
copyright law it will generally hurt the
folks that you're trying to help and
help the folks that you're trying to to
get protection from it's just the way
those laws are constructed
um so I'm not sitting here saying that
stuff is easy but I will tell you that
it's a heck of a lot simpler than people
are making it out to be and you have to
start somewhere so yes a lot of the
tools right now are very blunt but they
will definitely get less blunt as we go
along and we certainly don't want to do
nothing
yeah can I ask about that because you
know in in a way it seems like you're
you want to bring back or maybe you know
I realistically probably has never gone
away but this idea that there's a
guardian class that must control what
people are exposed to because they
really can't handle things they can't
sort things out themselves
um and you know this goes back to when
the novel was introduced when radio was
introduced movies you know comic books
Etc rock music in particular you know
and I think about uh you know your
documentary on Zappa you know this is
relevant with there's certain types of
material which should not be permitted
um because it will have a negative
effect on people who can't understand it
or can't critique it
um is there you know is there a
contradiction in what you're saying
between you know your earlier work and
your kind of emphasis on people being
allowed to express themselves no because
I think we're talking talking about
there's an enormous enormous
um spread there and I think that if
you're with disinformation being
information that is specifically created
to cause harm
um those are basic safeguards I don't
think there's a lot of that doesn't
enter sort of free speech territory
um you know if someone's being called
upon to go kill trans people and someone
goes and kills a trans person no I I
think it you know well if it's I mean
there's fighting words and true threats
that are you know have been worked
through yeah right but I mean it does
showing the impact of fighting words on
actual fighting and I think that that is
where the arguments for everything being
fair game are not valid
um so I mean and so like when Stephen
Crowder says we need a civil war because
my
you know God you know boy God Trump is
being uh investigated by the the FBI
that that crosses a line that if
somebody's saying you know what we need
a total reordering of society based on
recent political events that would be
sure I mean it's also intentionally
being done and funded by by some by dark
money interests that are trying to
create these Harms in this violence you
know as we saw with the Trump indictment
from yesterday the intention with the
January 6th Insurrection was to kill the
enemy it was actually to commit that
violence more people were radicalized to
go to the January 6th Insurrection by
YouTube than any other internet based
platform that is a a study with actual
numbers attached to it so you've got to
start somewhere
there's yeah I'm not I'm not convinced
of that I mean January 6 was organized
in you know WhatsApp groups Facebook
groups I mean private you know uh
encrypted Communications the people who
shut up the proliferation of the
ideology was proliferated by YouTube I
mean the Bella cam study is is very
comprehensive
uh yeah
you know the there there's
um the near the end of the film you
start introducing some possible policy
prescriptions you bring up the famous
internet law or you know very uh kind of
Bedrock internet law section 230 of the
communications and decency act and uh
that uh is essentially says that
platforms are not liable for user
generated content on their platforms uh
you know whether or not they moderate or
don't moderate just you know getting
involved with moderation does not mean
you're suddenly liable for every single
thing that someone posts on your
platform
this has been something that's been
attacked by both Democrats and
Republicans and your film seems to also
uh call for some sort of Reform needed
around section 230 what is what is it
that you would like to see changed about
that that fundamental law of the
internet
um actually it doesn't uh the film
doesn't do that
um in fact I would argue that we that
our general take
um not that might take is that important
because we're really just trying to show
all sides around this debate but section
230 is an incredibly difficult uh thing
to reform and it is really what provides
the safeguards for the internet period
um and tampering with it in a uh in a
blunt way would actually as I said
before cause harm to the very people
that
um that we that many people would be
looking to protect and it would it would
hyper Empower uh the monopolies there's
a reason why certain factions in
extremist sides of of political thinking
want to abolish 230 because uh it would
essentially
um allow for an enormous amount of
censorship
um and it would erase enormous amounts
of content from the internet that is
providing very important
um uh views and and giving voice to
people who need Voice who would not have
it without 230.
um so my general feeling on this stuff
is 230 content moderation all of it just
to be very clear is that none of this is
easy or simple and there really isn't a
there is not a clearly defined way
forward to say police the internet or
regulate the internet there isn't one
um my point is that the the impact of
these platforms on society is inarguably
huge
um that some of these Farms are
politically motivated and funded or just
ideologically motivated and funded and
that should be called out and that we
shouldn't as Citizens sit on the
sidelines and just throw up our hands
and say well this stuff's too
complicated we shouldn't do anything we
should start to look at what we can do
what however that looks I'm not
convinced that's by reforming 230
personally but I'm also not I'm not the
head of Ethics at Berkeley like honey
faridas right who does believe there's a
way you should ask honey right right so
how how do you how do you look at the
revelations of things like the Twitter
files and and reason got a cache of
documents from Facebook where you know
this is also something not quite new but
it you know it became apparent that
there was a huge amount of government
censorship without calling it that where
you know people in both the Trump
Administration the bite Administration
we can certainly assume you know George
W bush and Obama as well saying to
platforms hey de-prioritize that kill
this don't push this
um does that change the complexity of
the task that uh that is at hand that
this idea that there is private you know
the private sector in the public sector
public speech private speech is kind of
out the window now
I think that it it does which is good is
it shows the specificity of it which is
something we're talking about in the
film that there are ideologies at play
there are political players at play it
isn't just the Town Square there are
people with agendas that are funded
funded agendas that are giving that are
using this golly you as parasocial
influencer to say very specific things
or to attempt behind the scenes to
curtail the saying of very specific
things so I actually think it's
important that we understand that
politics and and certain players are
involved in trying to shape the language
or curtail the language that's out there
I think that's the look these are the
beginning of conversations that we need
to have this this is by no means the end
of anything that was an excerpt from our
conversation with Alex Winter the
director of the new documentary the
YouTube effect tell us what you think in
the comments and if you want to see
another excerpt go here if you want to
see the whole conversation and you
should go here and make sure to come
back every Thursday at 1pm on Eastern
Time
to check out a new live stream from
reason TV